hey what's going on it's bill burns it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
for monday
uh november 22nd
2021 what's going on how why yeah
um
wait november 22nd isn't that the jfk
day
isn't that uh the infamous day how many
years ago was it 1963 was almost six 58
years ago
58 years ago
who do you think did it you know what i
figured it out
i figured it out you know why because i
have the internet
and when you have the internet
okay and limited intelligence you can
figure out all of the world's mysteries
just by googling
just googling things like who really
shot jfk
see and that's the problem with the
authorities
you know what they're too smart to just
ask the simple questions
like let's find out right here
well you know what in honor of the 58th
anniversary of the assassination
of uh jfk we're gonna i'm gonna finally
debunk
you know the oswald thing who
really
killed jfk okay here we go
um free stock footage all right i got
stock footage 347 result
uh we got jfk conspiracies i don't want
all of this [ __ ] i just want an answer
i want
why people think this photo of jfk's
killer is fake
jfk kennedy's assassination conspiracy
theories all right that's wikipedia okay
here we go who really killed jfk
all right that's a book
oh you've mother [ __ ] you turned it
into a money i i can't just
i have to read i don't wanna read
i just wanna annoy people at the bar
go out there and say ah you know what it
was the [ __ ] guy who eventually
created target
yeah he wanted to open
a uh
a location and he didn't want to do it
oh my god you know what [ __ ] all of this
i got all right hats off to jfk
conspiracy theorists if you can [ __ ]
weave your way through all of that you
want to hear my theory i think i think
that that [ __ ] uh
lee harvey oswald was a part of it
that's all i know because when he walked
off so i'm the patsy that's from for me
that's it right there oh so i'm the
patsy
just the way he delivered the line it
was kind of like o.j when they arrested
o.j he didn't look like a guy who just
found out his ex-wife got murdered and
he was being charged
that was not the look he had like god
damn it
oh i had a rough one last night you know
all that that that [ __ ] jerk off
there
the kid from illinois that decided to
drive up into the [ __ ] riot that that
that [ __ ] crying he was allegedly
that was that is the worst fake crying i
have seen since miss new york
remember that what the [ __ ] was that
flavor of love and that girl called her
out going like oh my god you're amazing
i've never seen somebody cry without any
tears before and she goes that's cause
that oh that's cause it's an inner cry
[ __ ]
he was having an inner cry
um
he had a right to be there it was open
carry he felt threatened it was the
[ __ ] perfect murder
that might be enough to convince some
people
you know
if the picture where he's wearing a
shirt it says free as [ __ ] and he's
doing that stupid white supremacist
thing what oh he's saying a-okay
i'm happy to be free
uh you know
not picking sides there people i'm just
saying you know what i mean
the same way you're looking at oj being
like uh you know that guy did that [ __ ]
you know
[Laughter]
but whatever people get all wrapped up
in the other crap you know so
uh you might be right hey maybe maybe
you know maybe what he said was what
happened i'm just saying you know that's
just my opinion
my opinion was the the [ __ ] shoulders
going
the whole thing was horrible
uh it looked like student film
crying
um anyways plowing ahead
i had a great day yesterday
enjoy it my freedom
um out in uh
i went i went oh you know what i was in
las vegas this weekend
and uh had two really really fun shows
um at the cosmopolitan so thank you to
everybody that showed up
um
[Music]
i got to work with my buddy richarlia
and uh
and then we all hung around the next day
and we went to the uh the raiders
versus the cincinnati bengals which you
guys all know
was the team paul brown
started
after the cleveland browns and art model
you know showed him the door the guy
invented modern day football i believe
the coach that bill belichick looks up
to
the guy who understand understood the
importance of the the kicking game
and had a player named lou groza
lou the toe groza
um
anyway
then he went down that's why their
helmets were the sort of the same color
as the brown so they were like all right
you at least have to put
the word bengals on the side which they
eventually did and then they came up
with that
you know
i would call it a cougar print
you know a woman of a certain age would
wear a shirt in that design to let you
know that she's out there and she's
still feeling frisky
um anyway we went to uh the raiders
allegiance the radius allegiant stadium
and it was [ __ ] amazing thank you to
chris for hooking us up over there
uh we sat on the mezzanine level
i swear to god we were sitting in these
chairs
and uh
they looked like first class seats on a
[ __ ] airplane and there was nobody in
front of us
or maybe there was i can't remember
there was so much space and you had like
a little tv to share so you could
immediately watch the replay down there
as if the jumbotron wasn't big enough
um
and i i don't think i i don't think i've
ever enjoyed being at a football game
more
um
it was just uh
the food was great
they had short ribs mashed potatoes
and uh
i don't know what else was with it it
was absolutely [ __ ] delicious i made
sure that i didn't overeat
um when i was there and then i got to
watch a really great
game two evenly matched teams the spread
was minus one bengals
and uh they just were going back and
forth nobody could really seem to score
um although on that was it a fumble
recovery
that kid i don't know if he stayed to
the outside looks like he looked like he
had a clear lane to the end zone he cut
back inside it might have been a pic i
can't remember
but uh joe burr
and joe mixon
you know the story of the game was the
raiders front four they were 80s i felt
like they were just controlling the game
and um
bengals ended up finally making some
adjustments
because it was looking like in the first
quarter and a half like this was gonna
be the raiders game but i think they
left some points on the board and then
they just took one stupid penalty after
another one [ __ ] pass interference
call but other than that they just no
stupid personal files just dumb dumb
dumb [ __ ] playing
and um they ended up not winning the
game but uh we couldn't have a better
better time and it was driving me nuts
there was this guy
you know sitting in the section like the
row across and i kept looking at his
face going i [ __ ] know that guy who
is that guy
um
and afterwards when we were leaving the
game
um
i finally asked the the
uh chris
i go who was that guy i know i know that
face and he told me it was mike utley
who was the uh
former nfl player uh for the detroit
lions unfortunately had a neck injury
uh got paralyzed but um i would have
loved to have said hello to that guy
um
you know just a
i don't know freaking legend of the nfl
and the way he's handled
that
horrible day that happened to him i
really wish i got a chance to say what's
up to him but um anyway
the raiders um
stadium
is legit it is worth the trip all you
football fans out there who are thinking
hey you know what would be awesome is to
get a crew of my friends
go out to vegas
have a great time on friday and saturday
and then watch our team play the raiders
you 100 should do it
it's an absolutely beautiful stadium and
just their colors the black and the and
the silver
they have that theme throughout the
whole thing
and they had just unbelievable uh
memorabilia up on the wall
um
i didn't see this uh one of my buddies
mike was out there and he took a a
picture of they had one of the original
raider like from the afl days like their
warm-up jacket
hanging on the wall uh i love all that
type of stuff and then they had these
really cool framed pictures of like
where i was sitting it was let me see
who it was it was uh
mike haynes
i literally forget the other two i was
so surprised
because sometimes there's a patriots fan
maybe i blocked it out
because i remember when they they shut
down the redskins when they won that
last super bowl 83 was mike haynes and i
want to say maybe lester hayes
and they shut down
the redskins wide receiver says they
were trying to go back to back
um who the [ __ ] was it
i don't know i don't remember but they
had all these frame pictures oh eric
dickerson
played one season with the raiders then
they had a picture of mike haynes who
played i think from 82 to 89
and then they had one other person i
can't remember but uh
it was absolutely uh it was incredible i
didn't want the game to end i was having
so much fun then so thank you to
everybody that
uh hooked us up out there um
and with that my wife my wife came out
to vegas
and um
i ended up uh
you know on saturday we got up early
because i wasn't an idiot i didn't stay
out late after friday's show
and uh i gotta tell you something man if
you get up and you hit the strip at
about 9 a.m there's nobody there
nobody all the degenerates are still
sleeping off
what the hell they did the night before
still doing blow that you know that
hooker they met or whatever
so
we ended up walking down
all the way down to uh
the venetian
you know rather than go you know on a
treadmill or something let's take a walk
down the strip so we went down the strip
and uh i always wanted to go on those
gondola rides
you know
but you know i'm not gonna sit there as
a guy by myself go on a friggin boat and
have some guy going for larry is he's
[ __ ] paddle me around
so but i remember when the i'm so old i
remember when the venetian opened i know
i was only like 20 25 years ago
but when i first started working vegas
like
they were imploding the dunes the sands
all of that
and uh i remember when all of that [ __ ]
was being built the uh the paris
the luxor
uh new york new york
had just been built i believe
um
i remember when they finished the rio
and it was off the strip and that was
the hottest [ __ ]
casino uh there was
um
[Music]
i remember treasure island one of them
had like a volcano out front i don't
know if they still have that
i thought treasure island had the uh
the pirate ship or something whatever so
eventually yeah then the wind came along
encore all of that
uh the stratosphere all of that [ __ ] in
the last like 25 30 years was built
so it was either just brand new or was
now you know now being open and now i'm
looking at it like
like you know they're starting to get
like long in the tooth like something
that's 30 years old now is like long in
the tooth it's [ __ ] crazy
um
but i do love the older ones that still
survive
uh
like the flamingo bally's is still there
caesar's the mirage
all of that stuff's there i would have
loved to gone down to old vegas but um
my wife and i had such a good time
that she was mentioning that she'd like
to go back out there again so i think i
might go out there and and just like not
have anything to do and just go to some
shows and hang out i don't know why i
never did it's a [ __ ] 50-minute
flight
it was just a great time so we ended up
going down there and
you know we just sort of walk around
like hey you want to take a ride on
those gondolas
so we went inside and i always thought
that
like you could take a ride like
you go from the outside into the casino
and then back out again but those two
things are not connected
so all it really is is when you walk
into the uh
venetian the way they have the water set
up you can't tell where it goes or
whatever it kind of looks like it keeps
going but it doesn't you just kind of go
from one side you go underneath the
bridge
they do like a little 360 to give you a
whole view of everything that's going on
then you go back through the tunnel they
do another 360 and they drop you off
it's like 10 12 minutes but it's still
[ __ ] awesome
and um
we got this great uh person to do it and
uh everybody else kind of had that
obnoxious
[ __ ] voice but she had like a disney
pixar voice
it was
when you went in the tunnel she sang
these songs and just absolutely crushed
it my wife's having a good time she puts
her head on my shoulder i'm like all
right
you know it's going great here we're
having a good time so we're sitting
there you know you kind of get lost in
it you know you're just kind of like
right there and as we came out of the
tunnel she sang this beautiful song
and um i could tell my wife oh my god
that's romantic she was having such a
good time so we're sitting in a little
boat
and all of a sudden this guy is like
leaning over the rail and he just yells
out to me he goes hey buddy coming out
to see you tonight man looking forward
to it
totally killed the moot
you know which isn't his fault i mean he
was only like [ __ ] three feet away
but you kind of you know you're on the
boat you kind of feel like you're out on
a lake
um he kind of destroyed my mirage that i
had actually taken my wife out on a boat
trip rather than some little [ __ ]
ride but i will tell you
um
if you go out there with your wife it's
definitely a uh
definitely a great thing to do and
i actually started
i started uh
the first time when i used to work vegas
i used to work at harris
uh at the improv which i don't even
think is there anymore
and um
[Music]
i was sitting there you know where my
window to my hotel room i could look
down the strip and see every [ __ ]
place that i played
as i worked my way over to the uh the
cosmopolitan
and that's like you know what happens
when you work in vegas and then
eventually you want you work your way
back down
you know as you become 80 90 years old
and then you end up off the strip but
you know what you still give him a
[ __ ] show you saved your money so
you're still in a good mood
so you have your tuxedo dry cleaned so
you still look sharp
and people could say you know that faux
freckle still has it
his beard is all white but you know he's
hanging in there he's angrier than ever
um
so oh i also got to uh
i got to hang out uh with brad garrett
who's got a great comedy club over at uh
mgm
and i've been meaning to uh
meet up with them it just has never
worked out and i finally got to hang out
with them
and there's this famous story
of brad garrett
uh he was opening for frank sinatra way
back in the day when he was just a kid
and he was bombing
so when he said goodnight
he's like thanks a lot i've been brad
garrett you know stick around for frank
is what he said
obviously is a joke you know and he gets
off stage and this is back when the mob
was running it
and they came into his dressing room
they're like hey uh what
frank wants to know what you meant by
that
and he's like what i meant by what and
they go uh
stick it to frank
why why'd you say stick it to frank and
he goes uh no i didn't say stickers
frank i said stick around for frank
and they were like well
why wouldn't they stick around for frank
they're here to see frank
he's like no no that was like the joke
and they're like
stick around for frankie are you
suggesting he's late
because he's not
you're making it sound like he's late
all the time
he had this big [ __ ]
misunderstanding with him i probably
[ __ ] the story up but he was telling
me all of those
those stories and i was telling him some
stories i had some from some buddies of
mine that
um used to open up for rodney
dangerfield and that's one of my
favorite things
about going to vegas is i always look up
to see what comics are in town
and then i try to hang out with them
afterwards uh if i can so
oh and i also forgot the sports book
went down to that
on saturday and watched a bunch of
college football
oh that was it i took my wife on the
gondola ride so she was psyched and then
she was gonna go do some spa [ __ ] so
then i went down with the fellas
and i watched the uh ucla
congratulations jesus christ was the
last time they painted the bell i didn't
even know they did that
uh finally beat usc i don't know after
how many years and uh i watched the
alabama game
against arkansas and then i was also
watching a little bit of that wisconsin
nebraska game great games and then on
sunday when i went to the raiders game i
picked four games last week and i oh
freckles went 4-0
4-0 i had the bengals minus one
um i just thought the raiders were gonna
be a little bit of disarray with
everything that's been going on you know
losing their coach and all of that [ __ ]
and i didn't even hear about that other
horrific incident um
but despite that they still played great
i had uh kansas city
i had the steelers versus the chargers i
thought i'd lost that bet like 50
[ __ ] times
i was traveling i flew back i missed
every second of that game that seemed
like a wild one and then i had one other
one
i forget the other one that i had there
hold on i got my bets written down right
here
for those you not watching the anything
better podcast
um
i uh me and verzi have been
competing for the entire season
who did i have
oh i had the vikings plus one and a half
at the uh the packers for some reason i
just you know division rivalry i just
thought the packers might have a little
bit of a letdown game they got looked
like they got down early because i was
at the raiders game if i haven't
mentioned 50 times
um
then they came roaring back because they
have aaron rodgers the great aaron
rodgers and then um
i guess they hung on right went into
overtime oh that's right they scored a
[ __ ] touchdown i thought i had it one
and then two seconds later i'm looking
at the jumbotron
dude i don't know how many comeback
victories just even just you know or if
you threw in the ties aaron rodgers has
but he's one of the best to ever do it
um but then the vikings got a field goal
and all freckles covered with 4-0
last three weeks i went 4-0-0-4-4-0
feast or famine
but here's what i really want to talk
about
my new england patriots who i missed the
entire game i totally spaced that it was
thursday
and that there was a game i missed the
whole [ __ ] game and all my pats fans
were rape friends were raving about it
and i saw some highlights and i have to
tell you something in honor of the
holiday season
okay it's beginning to look a lot like
the 2001 patriots
when tom was just a kid
we had a great d
and tom wouldn't [ __ ] up
he'd throw a weight out of
bounds
that's what max mack jones is doing
the throw is there he's throwing it if
it isn't he's throwing it away
you gonna throw it away he's doing it
and i gotta tell you something what the
[ __ ] is going on in buffalo what in the
[ __ ] is going as their injuries i don't
understand what is happening out there i
almost took the colts because carson
wentz scores points that's what that
[ __ ] man does
but i was like the bills have just been
playing so shitty lately and then with
this offensive juggernaut earlier in the
season they i was too afraid that they
were going to come home and put up some
points so i stayed away from the game
i don't know what is going on at buffalo
but i'll tell you right now
you do not want to play bill belichick
from november on you just do not want to
do it when he's got a [ __ ]
quarterback and he's got [ __ ]
receivers and he has a [ __ ] defense
you do not want to do that i don't know
if we have receivers but you know
we do have a defense
all right
poor cam newton came in last year we had
we had nothing
so it's good to see him uh
back in the league
and back with the panthers as they were
sitting there trying to act like he
never even happened
um
glad that whole thing worked out but i
don't know what's going on with the
[ __ ] buffalo bills but i know the
patriots still have yet to play them so
we have to play them twice
and i think we actually have a chance
we'd have to beat him twice i would
think
that uh let me see here
let me see here patriots
standings
see where where are we
the [ __ ] are you the bills are six and
four
i'll tell you nothing will make you
we're in first [ __ ] place
what
well we won like five in a row
holy [ __ ]
the dolphins have won three in a row did
you guys see that footage of that
[ __ ] old guy that jets fan
throwing the haymakers shout out to that
dolphin fan slipped the first one they
made the second one just be a glancing
blow with his [ __ ] hands in his
pockets
the kansas city chiefs have won four in
a row they're in first place
the ravens are seven and three the
titans
eight and three jesus christ they lost
to the [ __ ] texans figure that one
out
is travis henry that bigger part of
their team
wow
these other than the ravens i think
they've been playing the titans been
playing well all year
these [ __ ]
divisions just flipped
i haven't looked at the stanza i think
since like september
cowboys are seven and three
the cardinals are nine and two i knew
that they were doing well
rams seven and three lost two
packers
the buccaneers are in first place ah
what am i talking about i thought we had
a
shot winning the super bowl because i
thought a lot of these uh
veteran teams look that brady's still in
it aaron rodgers is still in it
what do we got
patrick mahomes is still in it
oh this is going to be okay [ __ ] all of
that [ __ ] everything that i was just
thinking all right but you know we're
turning it around
um
i think with the defense that we have
bill belichick this is such an obvious
statement can is really going to
frustrate
a lot of teams uh i don't know kansas
city if they if they right the ship
because what was going on with kansas
city made no sense the whole [ __ ]
year
they didn't really lose anybody nobody
was hurt they just weren't playing well
and everybody did you know did they
figure them out
then i love them they do the usual thing
they're asking if their [ __ ] coach is
overrated how are you overrated after
you win a [ __ ] super bowl that's like
ed oger on
giving him [ __ ] i think he was [ __ ]
overrated what the [ __ ] you talking
about he won a national championship
you need the quarterback he doesn't have
the quarterback now
oh that kills me that [ __ ] kills me
only only sports fans could you win a
championship and then they still say
you're [ __ ] underrated
sports fans with no ring at any level
at any [ __ ] level so
anyway i'm talking way more [ __ ]
football than i thought i was going to
but what do you want from me i went to
levi
stadium lambeau field
and then i pledge allegiance stadium
the last three weeks this is like what i
used to do when i was a young young and
single
now i'm old and bald and i got two kids
so i usually come back from the road but
it's just been working out that the you
know
the games have been there
49ers played during the afternoon and a
show that night i did hang for lambo i
had i mean come on that's where the nfl
started basically i had to go there
and uh i brought my wife out
to vegas you know
did you bring it to the football game no
all right i was an absentee father the
last two sundays because i went to a
packers in a raiders game what do you
want from me all right all right plowing
ahead here
um
i got uh
i got to play drums tonight
at the goddamn comedy jam i'm also going
to be on jimmy kimmel tonight promoting
season the fifth and final season of f
is for family
uh it's gonna be out on netflix
november 25th uh thank you to everybody
at gomont netflix
wild west
um
everybody last night we had the final
wrap party which was so awesome
to see everybody but it was definitely
uh
you know a little melancholy bittersweet
because uh you know i made i made sure i
took it all in because that was one of
those things where i'm like this whole
group of people is not going to be
together like this ever again
because there was a whole bunch of
people there and just i'm going to run
into all of these people but we'll never
all be together again as the f is for
family crew and the proudest thing
that i had with everybody from editors
to the people that made the music to the
writers to the performers all came up to
me and told me how much fun they had
working on the show
which is um
[Music]
which is the best compliment and i think
that was because of
the great mike price
um
who was the showrunner and just you know
ran the ship and everything and um
i just think anything you know if the
person at the top is being cool and
being nice then everybody just kind of
falls into line so
fortunately that is the experience that
i had
over there so thank you to mike price
and everybody else over there
and of course
um
shout out to the late great mark wilmore
and uh the late great david richardson
um
you know those guys i learned so much
from them in the writers room
you know cannot say
enough about them
and um
and then of course michael k williams
uh who played smokey rest in peace to
him too uh but i mean
i don't know it was my head's still
spinning i can't believe it's over but
i'm so thankful that i got the
experience and i'm actually
it's better that we're ending before
fans want us to rather than going too
long so please watch it enjoy it tell
your friends about it
and uh thank you for everybody who
watched over the years so we could do
five seasons of this wonderful show all
right and with that let's do some um
let's do some uh advertising here oh
look who it is everybody it's oh helix
helix
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattresses
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains and even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door ship for free
you don't even need to go to a mattress
store again just go to
helixsleep.com take the two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk-free
they'll even pack they'll even pick it
up for you
if you don't love it gross but you will
helix even has financing options and
flexible ladies payment plans so a great
night sleep is never far away helix is
offering up to 200
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helixsleep.com
h-e-l-i-x for up to 200 off all mattress
orders and
two
free pillows
okay oh boy our old friends indochino
people have gotten a little too used to
wearing sweatpants
replace the suit that's been gathering
dust in your closet and bring looking
great back into style i know everybody's
dressed down fridays right
it's not just about looking great it's
about feeling confident and standing out
there's never been a better time to
upgrade your look indochino's black
friday events has their lowest prices of
the year on suits shirts outerwear and
more plus you'll save even more using
code bur indochino offers completely
customized fitted suits shirts casual
wear and more at a surprisingly at
surprisingly affordable prices get
wardrobe personalized to your style and
taste without spending a fortune measure
yourself on the website in 10 minutes
then wear your suit out of the box in
three to four weeks every piece is made
to your exact measurements and you can
customize every detail choose everything
about your suit including the fabric
lapel monogram and statement linings you
can create a suit that fits you and your
style perfectly the best part is
indochino suits start at just 2.99 and
shirts from 45 with all customizations
include get away from the video calls
and back into looking and feeling
amazing indochino's black friday event
runs from november 20 november 8th to
november 29th save even more and get 50
off any purchase of 3.99 or more by
using promo code bur at indochino.com
that's 50 off a purchase of 3.99 or more
at i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code burp
oh my god i forgot to give roy choi a
shout-out
that best friend restaurant
um
my lovely wife neil hooked that up and
we went down there with me and all my
friends the great dave kushner
it was his birthday weekend he did all
the music on efforts for family
you might know him from velvet revolver
um we went over there and
i think uh roy choi's goal was to uh
have our stomachs burst he just kept
bringing the food out we had to tap out
um what an amazing amazing cool guy that
guy is man that guy is the best in his
food was insane
and then
all the food was so good over there that
we would we all debated which which um
which dish we liked the best
personally i loved the street corn
and there was a uh a short rib thing
that he had
uh
i love the kimchi
and then there was like four or five
other and then the desserts were
absolutely crazy so needless to say
uh old freckles needs to get back on his
diet um all right
continuing with the uh
with the advertising simply safe
you know if you ever wanted to make your
home feel safer
there is no better time than now this
week my friends at simply safe are
giving my listeners early access to all
their black friday deals 50 percent off
their award-winning home security i love
simply safe because it has everything
you need to make your home safe
indoor and outdoor cameras comprehensive
sensors you know what's great about the
indoor outdoor cameras you can also
catch the varmints that go into your
trash cans you have your own little
nature show can't believe what goes on
outside your house
uh at night uh all monitored around the
clock by trained professionals who send
help the instant you need it simply safe
was even named best home security system
of 2021 by u.s news and world report you
can easily customize a system for your
home online in minutes and even get free
custom recommendations from simply safe
these are simply safe's business biggest
discounts of the year you can get a
complete home security system starting
just a hundred dollars there's no
long-term contracts or commitments it's
a really easy way to start feeling a bit
more peace of mind take advantage of
simply safe
er simply saves early black friday deals
and get 50 off your new home security
system by visiting simply
safe.complisafe.com
uh again that's
simplysafe.com 50 off your entire
system
um all right one more here people oh
look what it is it's solo stove
this just sounds like something you'd
bid on
unlike the price is right
but no that's out of the way
that was i dream of genie
the price is right had a little jingle
something like that
when you'd sit there and everyone would
like write it down and try to think
i don't know
i was watching this thing you know bob
barker's still alive he's 99 gonna be
100 years old next year and i didn't
realize this late to the party in 2015
on april fool's day they introduced drew
carey to come out and bob barker came
out and he did the first item up for
bids which of course was a new car and
then after that drew carey came out what
a great idea huh i wish i saw that live
i would have freaked out
one of the great um
television personalities of all time
there was nothing like fake and sick
and staying home you know
and your parents went off to work and
then you didn't have to [ __ ] fake
sick anymore
right i'd sit there in my pajamas and i
would always watch the prices right
uh
solo stove you know there's nothing
quite like the feeling of gathering
around a warm fire
on a cool evening and a smokeless fire
pit from solo stove makes your outdoor
moments even more memorable
can't you see this next item up for bid
what do you got for us robert it's a
solo stove
uh because instead of having to
constantly dodge campfire fumes you can
sit back relax and actually enjoy the
fire i know because you know it's a
little bit windy
you know the wind shifts and all of a
sudden it just you know
afterwards you smell like you fought a
fire you don't have to deal with that
anymore with solo stove and with solo
sloves solo stoves black friday sale you
can get a great deal on a solo stove
fire pit upgrade your backyard with the
solo stove fire pit solo stove if you
don't know what the [ __ ] it's called
jesus christ fire pits are brilliantly
engineered easy to light with a few bits
of starter your fire is blazing in
minutes perfectly portable take solo
stove with you on a camping on camping
trips
and more you [ __ ] cheater
supposed to be out there rubbing sticks
together
um
shop solo stoves best deals of the year
during their black friday sale now
through november 28th and get ten
dollars off with promo code burr burr
plus a lifetime warranty and free 30-day
returns get an extra 10 off black friday
deals at solo stove
s-o-l-o-s-s-t-o-v-e dot com promo code
bird
bird burr b-u-r-r
all right
and with that let's get on to some of
the uh some of the reads here that we
have for the week all right
naked
hotel dude
um yeah a buddy of mine accidentally
locked himself
out of his hotel room last week
completely naked
he doesn't have the best eyesight he had
had a couple of pops and he was trying
to find the bathroom door he thought he
did he opened it
the door closed behind him and he's like
that's not a toilet
um he was out in the hallway had to
cover his junk walk down and go get the
uh go get the keys
and everybody laughed and some woman
slapped him on the ass all right here we
go now you're caught up naked hotel dude
dear billy barbage um after hearing the
story of the naked guy in the hotel
i thought i would share a story from my
stag too
this is stag do do i'm thinking stag two
as an also your stag party all right 16
of us went to glasgow
uh
on a minibus that's in scotland for all
you americans out there like me the only
reason why i know that's cause i've been
there and also
if you want blood you got it the live ac
dc album
was uh
was uh recorded there that's why in the
jack he goes any versions in glasgow
um in the beginning
she was number nine
all right uh and you know that one
aggressive
and you know that one aggressive let me
start over again uh 16 of us went to
glasgow on a mini bus and you know that
one aggressive lightweight friend who
can't handle his booze well he decided
to crack a bottle of jack daniels at 7am
oh jesus he fell asleep before we
arrived and upon arrival i had the
unfortunate task of waking him as soon
as he opened his eyes he had a crazed
startled look on his face and he
absolutely stinks of booze cigarettes
and [ __ ] oh no
he proceeds to ring his wife and start
crying angie angie it happened again
it's then apparent he has [ __ ] his pants
we bundle him into the hotel lift
that's an elevator for everybody in this
side of the world and leave him there
well you guys aren't friends you just
left them in the whole
in the elevator
and we go out drinking
i mean that's just scotland rules all
right if you if you're gonna [ __ ]
pass out and [ __ ] yourself before 12
noon we're leaving you in an elevator
um all right well whatever when in
scotland you gotta act like scottish
people we get back to the hotel about
six hours later and the [ __ ] is still
in the lift
luckily the guy on the desk of the hotel
was brilliant and was having a laugh
about it he said people were returning
to the hotel pressing the lift and when
the doors open he was slumped in the
corner snoring stinking of [ __ ] and
people would just take the stairs
just
thought that would brighten your day
keep on the good work and go [ __ ]
yourself
wow
i mean that's a funny story but i can't
believe you just left them in there
oh god that smell just marinating as the
doors are closed holy [ __ ] literally
um
wow
i remember a long time ago me and my
friends we all skipped school a bunch of
us skipped school
we're so stupid everybody skipped school
in the same day so
i can't remember what happened but i'm
sure they figured out you know
when 30 seniors are all of a sudden all
not there on the same day
in a class of 200.
you know they probably knew something
was up but anyways we went down to the
cape cause that we just go down to the
cape and [ __ ] get [ __ ] out then drive
back so we all went down there
and i remember you know
all of these kids were there and one of
my buddies
he got sick and he was he
he was sitting on the couch
and there was like a breezeway door all
he had to do was get up
and go out and he didn't he just sat
there
this guy was he was a puker man and the
thing about him was he never knew when
he was gonna [ __ ] puke
i mean he one time was [ __ ] sitting
in the passenger seat in my buddy's car
and we're driving down the highway and
all of a sudden he just [ __ ]
projectiled onto the windshield
i think i told this story before and
used this reference it was like in pulp
fiction when he actually
we accidentally shot that guy in the
head and they just showed his [ __ ]
brains go on the on the uh
back windshield of the the whatever the
rear rear
window of the car it was like that
except it was the front windshield and
it was puke so he's sitting on the couch
and just out of nowhere he just pulls
the front of his t-shirt out up over his
[ __ ]
nose and mouth and just pukes down the
front of himself and everyone's like ah
alright so
then he gets up
it walks to where the breezeway is where
there's a porch
and proceeds to then just strip down to
his [ __ ] tidy whities
and every hot chick from my grade is
just standing there looking at him like
oh god
oh in one [ __ ] afternoon all of his
options were gone
but he was a senior so who cares he went
to college and a whole new boatload of
women came in that never saw that
horrific moment in his life uh sleeping
in public uh dear billy blankets i'm the
type of weirdo you described last week
who can sleep in public
i think you underestimate what a job
that requires
labor
can do to you what i think you
underestimate what a job that requires
labor
can do to you oh look at you taking a
swipe at stand-up comedy
um
i don't i i don't think i was
disrespecting oh what are you telling us
let me get this straight you work on a
construction site
and then you get on an airplane after
that was i talking about people that
sleep on airplanes
um
and i had jobs that required physical
labor i don't remember sleeping in a
[ __ ] train station and missing my
train
i don't know what to find or maybe just
giving me [ __ ] i wasn't disrespecting
people that work for a [ __ ] living um
i we have to be honest with you
uh if you fall asleep like that you're
not getting enough sleep
at night i would think because the only
the few times that i have ever fallen
asleep in public uh
that just reminded me the ron white joke
you threw me
into public
um
i think uh
yeah it was if i didn't get enough sleep
that was the only time i was like
passing out
um i was also amazed that you could fall
asleep in a place where you could get
the [ __ ] kicked out of you or get mugged
like train stations on the subway
you just see these people just like
[ __ ] nodding off
um
now i'm gonna get people well maybe they
you know they don't make a lot of money
and they need two [ __ ] jobs all right
maybe we could just take all the [ __ ]
fun out of it
um
all right
having said that i'm actually uh i'm
trying to get back into taking my old
man naps because i don't get enough
sleep
all right and what do you know about
[ __ ] labor sir
what what what job do you do that
requires [ __ ] labor huh
do you get heckled when you're bringing
[ __ ] wood the wrong way down to a
[ __ ] construction site and it gets
filmed and gets put up on [ __ ]
youtube huh
yeah i'm [ __ ] puffing my chest up
right back at you my job
all right
did you go on stage in las vegas in
front of a cross section of people and
do some jokes about that puffy lift kid
out there from illinois
and then have to dig yourself out of the
[ __ ] hole all right hey bill i hate
my girlfriends
okay
all right my girlfriend can't do
anything without complaining when i say
anything i mean anything
well okay when i say anything i mean
anything
things she has to do things she wants to
do things she doesn't want to do don't
get me wrong she gets [ __ ] done but has
to complain about it she thinks she's
this extraordinary motivator who puts
out positive vibes only oh boy
why is it all i hear out of her is the
negative in the situation i hear
people's problems
i don't know
and i don't care about this broad i
never met
or her fat baby
i can't tell if this is a man or a woman
writing this we're both from new england
so it's safe to assume she's loud and
yells and speaks
when she speaks and you'd be correct
the voice is so loud it's offensive to
my ears
she brags about going to the gym every
day we live together bill she might go
three times a week in a good week
oh i think he's trying to say i hate my
girlfriend
he wrote i hate my girlfriends
so i thought this was a woman saying she
needs to get new friends i don't know
what's going on here or maybe you live
in utah and you have girlfriends
on a way to having wives
um
all right she might go three times a
week to the gym days like today when i
come home from the gym to find my dog on
my pillow at 7 00 a.m
and i lay my head on my dog and my
girlfriend rolls okay so it's your
girlfriend rolls over and wraps her arms
around me i embrace it and i love it
now she'll never know how much that
moment meant to me now she'll never know
how much that moment meant to me because
i won't tell her
she's just gonna wake up and yell about
her mom texting her too early in the
morning and yeah i'll get annoyed but
moments like that is why i deal with her
[ __ ]
well that and her laundry skills peace
out bill
oh god
well i mean i think you resolved the
whole thing your girlfriend complains a
lot but when you come home you lay your
head on the pillow and she gives you a
hug
you know
you embrace it and you love it and she
does your laundry so i mean you know
everybody has i'm sure there's something
you do
that's bugging her there's really no
problem there sir
um
as far as what i could forecast in that
relationship is the day she stops
hugging you and doing your laundry uh
she better quit complaining too or that
relationship is gonna have
is headed for some white water
it's heading for the rapids man
is that a floating rock
all right
oh boy girl talk [ __ ] about me on
tick-tock
love the podcast and you stand up to
begin
i've been talking to this lady for two
weeks now and everything was perfect our
first date was last thursday and i had
taken her out to a nice korean barbecue
restaurant both of our favorites so look
at that
share something in common you know
what could go wrong dinner was great and
the conversation was flirtatious
i like your tits
thank you i was hoping you're going to
notice them
sorry i'm sure it was a little lighter
than that i paid the tab left
she then said she had a great time and
wanted a second date cooley i said sure
and asked for a kiss goodbye we made out
then said goodnight
day after no text at all
i then go on her tick tock and on her
live she states how she had a terrible
time and that was one of the worst dates
she had been on and she won't be dating
for quite some time i was obviously hurt
and angry as hell i confronted her about
it and she said
she sides hustles with her tick tock
it's all an act and she lies like that
for the monetary entertainment she's not
a public figure
parentheses gross get a [ __ ] job in
my opinion hey i'm a public figure
that's the second shot at my job i don't
work
i'm a disgusting public figure
hey man
anyway i still thought
that was two-faced of her but she
reconciled and she apologized oh boy
buddy i don't know about this
and said that if it was the opposite way
she'd feel the same way all right well
there's some empathy
she even messaged me back this morning
do i still talk to her but wait for a
second date on on her asking or do i
just ignore her for this thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself dude go with your gut
i'd go with my gut
and uh i think you don't respect what
she does for a living
you think it's gross get a [ __ ] job
and if you're gonna get into a
relationship with somebody you know i
really think uh
you know if you don't respect what they
do if you think what they do for a job
is gross before you've even had the
second date you might want to pull the
rip cord
and plus um
the fact that it's an act and she's
lying
i don't know dude
uh
i don't know
i don't know and that's one of those
things
you kind of have to worry about
i don't know these are all stereotypes
but i'm just throwing it out there just
like
all right so this person's really into
fame and money how they how any way that
they can do it
and going out there and just like lying
or whatever you know
i don't know i don't want to look down
on a fellow person that's whoring
themselves out but you know it's one
thing to go out and start a band tell
some jokes become an actor
[ __ ] i don't know
whatever else you do
run for office to try to change things
before they you know get their dirty
filthy mitts on you
um i don't know but then the other thing
too you know i think it's actually good
that hot chicks can [ __ ] go out there
and make money doing that because uh
now they're kind of in control
or back in the day you know they make
like you know even like nfl cheerleaders
wouldn't make any money and their whole
big thing was we'll wait till the
calendar comes out they pay him like 35
bucks a [ __ ] game
and uh but now there's like instagram
so they can just go on there and you
know do their little boo boopy doop
[ __ ] dance
and uh you know flirt with a couple of
you know [ __ ] ugly guys and they'll i
don't know i'm sure it's harder than
that
um
i don't know dude you're talking
tick-tock and and influencers
to a
53-year-old man so take everything that
i'm saying with a grain of salt i would
just go with my gut
and if you feel this early on
that you can't trust her and i also i
don't understand young people where they
feel like you're putting [ __ ] out on the
internet and like no one's gonna see
that
you know it's not even young people i
got a buddy of mine you
know i mean i a friend of mine from back
in the day the guy [ __ ] takes video
of himself
[ __ ]
rolling joints old school he still buys
the weed and wants to roll the joint
rolls the joints during his [ __ ]
lunch hour at work i mean figure that
one out
um
anyway uh
yeah i would go with my gut i
kind of don't like this though
she said she had a terrible time and
she's not going to date for a while
the only saving great is grace is that
she said
i understand that you feel that way i
would feel the same way
so you got to think is that empathy
and that's somebody that can actually
admit that they did something wrong
which is a great trait and very rare i
feel like in a lot of adults
or is this part of her hustle and she's
hustling you
go with your gut
i mean what really happened you went out
you flirted you had a good time and you
made out with her and she's a good
kisser other than that you think what
she did was gross and she lied about
your evening for money
i mean when you [ __ ] distill it down
to that i mean i think you can find a
nicer person than that
whatever i'm not going to judge you
either way good luck to you all right
thanksgiving pressure advice oh boy
dear billy chitlins
uh i'm going to my girlfriend's house
for thanksgiving
we've been together for four years and
i'm good with her family all right
she told me to bring something creative
because there will be a lot of the
standard things already there
i was oh my he goes i put this pressure
on myself because i insisted on bringing
something even when her family when he
her and her family said they would
already have a lot of food dude this is
like me years ago i don't know where i
said i'd make a pie
then i got that joke what if i slam my
head through this window and just bleed
out down the side of the house
so now i need to bring something that is
out of the box but also welcomed my
front runner idea is ice cream and then
i bring hot sauce to melt or heat up
or however it's done
wait hot sauce on ice cream is that a
stupid [ __ ] idea my brother says if i
do that i'm basically bringing a mess
over to their house
then i have to insist on doing dishes
thoughts help
um all right
a dessert is always great and a dessert
is easy so what i would do there's
always
in every town or every couple of towns
two three towns there's always that one
[ __ ] place
that's not a chain
that you can go out
and bring uh get something special that
you can bring over
um
i would do the dishes either way
and because you're four years in and you
still haven't gotten her a ring
uh so you got to stay on the good side
of the family while you sit down to
watch the lions game
um
or i would take a shot at making a
dessert which isn't that hard all right
i have a video up there on how to make a
pie crust
uh why don't you just follow that up
follow that
um
i actually have a better recipe for the
pie crust now but you can totally make a
pie crust and then the filling's the
easiest [ __ ] thing ever don't ever
get into intimidated by filling it's all
about the crust just you know something
if you make an effort to make a homemade
[ __ ] pie even if it stinks
all right the [ __ ] effort that you
made
they're gonna be psyched so what i would
do is i would make the pie the wednesday
before
have it ready to go
and uh you know if you your girlfriend's
like why are you doing that i just want
to show you you know how much i care
about you and your family
then you get the oh
and i think you'll be good even if it
sucks
and i would tell everybody before the
age say listen it's the first time i
ever tried to make a pie i will not be
offended at all if you guys say it sucks
all right but everyone will appreciate
the effort and then if you get up and
you you know
you do some dishes and that you drive
some or whatever
i think you'll be good
all right
take the pressure off
take a chance man take a chance why you
still got the choice
going ac dc today all right that's the
podcast everybody
um
what a run seven out of eight weekends i
was on the road i cannot thank people
in st louis denver minneapolis reno san
jose
atlanta
where the hollywood florida
las vegas
um i can't thank you guys enough for
still coming out after all these years
supporting my comedy i had an absolute
blast going up on stage
trying to make you laugh and uh thank
you to everybody in vegas chris and
everybody over at the raiders thanks to
roy choi for hooking us up and thanks to
my wife this i'm being thankful
thank you to my wife being so friggin
cool
and after all these years i can still
have such a great time hanging out with
her and thank you to uh everybody on
ephes for family
that helped all of these five seasons
come together and to all the fans that
have been watching please uh check it
out november 25th or sometime this
weekend if you get a chance that's it
happy thanksgiving to all of you
and uh and as always go [ __ ] yourselves
and i'll check in on you on thanksgiving
all right i'll see you
you